over the past year the world has been
dealing with a chip shortage crisis
impacting the supply of a wide variety
of tech related products but somehow
apple was not only able to survive
through the chip shortage but they've
absolutely thrived and have continued to
sell more products than they did the
years prior so in this video i'm gonna
go into exactly how apple was able to
pull this off despite the negative
environment but first i want to get into
the other industries and companies that
were impacted to give you a good idea of
how impressive this really is last year
many car companies halted production of
their vehicles because of the chip
shortage like ford with their most
popular f-150 truck general motors
cutting production at multiple plants
daimler shutting down production of a
few mercedes-benz models in alabama and
many more and now in 2021 it's actually
starting to get worse with the chip
shortage expected to cost the auto
industry 110 billion dollars in revenue
this year now in terms of tech ps5s have
been in a shortage for many months xbox
consoles have also been out of stock
everywhere and graphics cards for
desktop pcs have been in a huge shortage
over the past year even apple's main
competitors are getting hit really hard
like google saying that the pixel 5a
will only launch in two countries likely
due to a lack of chips smartphone maker
xiaomi says that they have to raise the
prices of their products because of the
shortage and samsung literally confirmed
that the galaxy note 21 is not coming
this year because of the chip shortage
which is absolutely insane on top of
that lg recently announced that they're
quitting the smartphone business
entirely since sales have not been doing
so well and huawei recently launched
their p50 and p50 pro chips without 5g
support because of sanctions and the
chip shortage now in the pc market dell
hp and lenovo have all recently warned
about low chip supply increasing the
production costs of their computers
causing them to raise prices asus and
msi are raising their graphics card
prices again
microsoft reported lower surface product
sales due to the chip shortage and acer
recently warned that the shortage will
impact laptop production until next year
so it's pretty obvious that every tech
related industry is getting hit pretty
hard but if you take a look at apple
they've somehow managed to escape the
grips of the chip shortage and post
record-breaking numbers ever since the
pandemic began apple has been destroying
wall street's expectations for revenue
and growth with a record 81.4 billion
for q3 2020 and even though they delayed
the iphone 12 by a month they still beat
expectations for q4 they then posted
multiple record-breaking revenues up 21
over year for quarter one of 2021 and
for quarter two it was even better with
sales up 54
year over year another blowout quarter
and just a couple of weeks ago they did
it again up 36
year over year so apple has obviously
been doing incredibly well despite many
other companies struggling through the
chip shortage and i believe that it was
due to a lot of quick and genius action
from apple along with a little bit of
perfect timing so now let's get into how
they pulled it off last year the
pandemic was causing issues like
lockdowns store closures and much more
which is a huge problem because apple
hosts various events throughout the year
to show off their products and software
but instead of canceling their wwdc
event in june like many other companies
would do they resorted to making it
online only and they absolutely went all
out the production quality of that event
blew everyone away with creative
background sets transitions animations
and excellent cinematography i still
don't know how they were able to pull it
off in such a short time especially
since they had to film and edit many
developer training videos as well on top
of that they acted very quickly with a
marketing campaign embracing people
working from home with this creative and
funny advertisement showing off the
various ways apple products can help you
with your work and despite having their
iphone 12 delayed they still hosted a
september event to release other
products that were ready to show off
like the ipad air and the apple watch
and for the first time ever they hosted
three events last fall all of them being
online only which was absolutely genius
because it helped them spread their
products out and have as big of a
marketing push as possible and many have
said that apple's spring event in april
was probably the best they've ever seen
with the release of the 24 inch imac and
the m1 ipad pro so marketing wise apple
absolutely nailed it not holding back
like many other companies did and
because of that sales have been
skyrocketing the iphone 12 reached a
hundred million sales in the first seven
months of launch actually outperforming
the iphone 11 which was released before
the pandemic hit and amazingly apple
sold 33 more ipads in 2020 than the
previous year and max sales have been
skyrocketing ever since the m1 max
launched late last year so the big
question is this how was apple able to
grow this much despite the chip shortage
that everybody else was getting impacted
by well the main part of the story has
to do with tsmc the biggest and most
advanced chip manufacturer in the world
which also happens to be the company
that has been making apple design chips
for many years for example every single
iphone since the iphone 7 comes with a
chip manufactured by tsmc and because of
tsmc being ahead of the game in terms of
chip making technology apple's iphones
and ipads have been one to two years
ahead of the main competition from
qualcomm and it isn't stopping there
because tsmc has just announced plans to
have two nanometer chips start
production in 2024 with construction of
a new plant beginning in early 2022
which is incredible and luckily for
apple they're actually tsmc's biggest
and most important customer and we know
that because tsmc themselves said that
they would prioritize apple and car
manufacturers during the chip shortage
with apple getting dibs on the best
chips out there just like they have in
the past when they reserved 100 percent
of tsmc's 5 nanometer production
capability and their entire next
generation three nanometer production
capability and on top of that apple is
already in talks with tsmc over their
two nanometer chips for future iphone
models in 2024 and that right there is
another part of apple's genius because
they think and plan their products years
in advance and since they're taking care
of tsmc in terms of booking chips in
advance they've become tsmc's number one
priority and that is one of the major
reasons why they haven't really been
impacted by the chip shortages that much
even today almost all of their products
are in stock and ready to ship like
their iphone 12 that has exceeded sales
expectations and on amazon you can get
an m1 mac mini for only six hundred
dollars with the coupon code and get it
in only two days along with the m1
macbook pro which is actually 200 off
even the m1 ipad pro is a hundred
dollars off right now while everybody
thought that it would be sold out and
waiting on more chips but it's not so
apple is obviously not facing any supply
shortages right now even after selling
record-breaking amounts of devices and
even today it seems like apple is
continuing to lock in chip supply to
make sure they have as many chips as
possible to get through this chip
shortage and a big reason why apple has
been able to do this is because of their
massive amount of cash on hand which
allowed them to continue ordering
massive amounts of the best chips out
there as well as pay for higher
transportation costs and now it seems
like apple is using that extra cash to
continue to lock and ship supply to make
sure they have as many chips as possible
to weather the chip supply storm which
intel ceo believes will last all the way
up into 2023 and this finally brings us
to the perfect timing of apple ditching
intel and switching to their own apple
design chips built by tsmc back in may
of last year apple updated their macbook
air and macbook pro with intel's latest
skylake 10 nanometer chips but there was
definitely some weirdness going on first
off for some reason the base macbook pro
stuck with an older eighth generation
chip instead of getting a new tension
ship like the more expensive eighteen
hundred dollar model received well as it
turns out intel admitted that their 10
nanometer isolate chips were doing
poorly in terms of performance and
yields and later that year it became
apparent that 10 nanometer chip yields
were actually really bad and that might
be the reason why the base macbook pro
stuck with 8th gen and on top of that
even today intel is continuing to delay
their chips like their 7 animator chips
in 2023
and their sapphire rapids survey chips
being delayed yet again so it's pretty
clear that if apple stuck with intel
their max sales probably wouldn't be
looking so good right now especially
with the whole chip shortage impacting
intel but thankfully apple literally had
perfect timing when they announced the
switch of their mac lineup to their own
apple silicon chips that are built by
tsmc which is not having that bad of
supply shortages and apple was
absolutely genius by only having a
single m1 ship design for four different
mac devices and the m1 ipad pro meaning
that tsmc could mass manufacture that
one ship to help improve yields as much
as possible and because of that and the
impressive performance of the m1 max
sales have been breaking records in
terms of sales growth quarter after
quarter since the release of the m1
champ and today apple isn't stopping
they've recently ordered a hundred
million a15 chips for their upcoming
iphone 13 and they brought on additional
suppliers to meet production targets and
they even started mass production of the
m1x chip months ago to make sure they're
gonna have enough supply when the 14 and
16 inch macbook pros are released this
fall which have also just entered mass
production with apple intending to sell
as many as 800 000 units by the end of
november which is massive and it was
recently reported that tsmc's arizona
plant will begin mass production in 2024
to build even more apple chips so if i
were to sum up the reasons for how apple
thrived through the chip shortage it
would be due to apple's relentless
forward-looking strategy with
reservations of chips from tsmc combined
with their genius marketing plans
embracing the lockdowns and how quickly
they were able to switch to online only
events which were somehow better than
the previous events so hopefully you
enjoyed this video and if you did go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
and definitely check out one of those
two right over there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]